andy on passe à notre débat de société
vous savez volontairement décalée de
l'actualité du jour et ce soir c'est
l'europe l'europe et les attaques
qu'elle subit de la part de presque tous
les candidats de droite qui nous
intéresse jambes ravi
euros sur l'union européenne un grand
classique des campagnes présidentielles
ils y allaient convaincu de longue date
à l'extrême droite comme marine le pen
qui revendique depuis longtemps la
primauté des lois françaises même si
désormais elle ne défend plus la sortie
de la france de l'union européenne pour
l l'immigration sera la mère des
batailles et les français seuls fort ont
leur mot à dire par référendum la
maîtrise des flux migratoires la
protection de la nationalité de la
citoyenneté française la suprématie de
la constitution et du droit français un
avis partagé par eric zemmour qui
s'attaque depuis longtemps à la cour de
justice de l'union européenne et à la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
mais ce discours est désormais largement
repris à droite y compris par ceux
considérés comme modérés nos lois
constitutionnelles elles doivent primer
notre identité constitutionnel à chacun
chaque état souverain doit primer la
juridiction européenne pour que l'on
soit plus dans cette situation
incontrôlée on n'a plus la maîtrise de
rien pour cela il faudra un référendum
eh bien les parlementaires peuvent
décider je demanderai aux français de se
prononcer sur cette question
même l'ancien commissaire européen
michel barnier qui a négocié pied à pied
avec le royaume uni lors du bric site
propose désormais de s'extraire
temporairement des traités européens en
la matière ce que j'appelais un bouclier
constitutionnel être capable de prendre
des mesures nationales pendant trois à
cinq ans dont nous avons besoin pour
maîtriser cette immigration qui ne l'est
pas aujourd'hui des attaques qui agace
au plus haut point bruxelles qui
rappelle que ces règles sont la base de
l'union européenne et de ses valeurs et
que ceux qui veulent s'en écarter
fragilise l'édifice européen
les attaques contre l'europe une vieille
maladie français je reprends titre de ce
débat une citation récentes du président
la république et ça va forcément faire
réagir mes invités je vous présente
marie françoise bechtel bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes présidente de la
fondation res publica qui a été créée
par jean pierre chevènement ancien
député de l'aisne vous êtes et vous avez
également été directrice de l'ena
bernard guetta bonsoir bonsoir européens
au sein du groupe renaissance hauteur de
l'enquète hongroise chez flammarion et
vous et vos analyses géopolitiques ont
bercé nos oreilles pendant de longues
années sur france inter patrick martin
jonnier bonsoir bienvenue à vous
enseigner en droit public spécialiste
des questions européennes vous publiez
l'europe at elle un avenir sécher
studyrama j'accueille également avec
nous en visioconférence jean paul
garraud magistrat et
eurodéputé du rassemblement national
bonsoir monsieur garraud laetitia peut
pas évidemment il rester à mes côtés
peut-être une définition pour commencer
patrick martin geniez la suprématie du
droit communautaire européen ça veut
dire quoi bah écoutez ça veut dire très
concrètement que la france et des pays
de l'union européenne ont accepté par
des traités internationaux
donnons pas de déléguer la souveraineté
mais de transférer un certain nombre de
compétences à l'union européenne dès
lors que ces traités sont exécutoires
nous acceptons dans les domaines où la
loi européenne et voter c'est à dire les
directives et de règlements que ces
dispositions s'appliquent directement en
droit interne ce sont les règlements ce
sont les directives qui sont votées par
les députés européens en matière
environnementale en matière de marchés
publics en matière de réglementation
européenne dès lors que nous avons
accepté librement et démocratiquement de
déléguer des compétences à l'union
européenne c'est ça la suprématie du
droit de l'union européenne mais
attention j'ai entendu des choses
fausses de dire que le droit européen a
été supérieure à la constitution ce
n'est pas vrai c'est la norme suprême en
droit national c'est bien la
constitution le bouclier constitutionnel
existe bien ça veut dire que si une
disposition de droit européen était
contraire à la constitution il faudrait
d'abord réviser la constitution c'est ce
que nous avons fait lors du traité de
maastricht alors on vient d'entendre
dans le dans le sujet précédent la
rafale de réactions des candidats de
marine le pen à arnaud montebourg en
passant par eric zemmour qui est pas
tout à fait candidat mais bon les trois
favoris de la primaire lr eux aussi
s'oppose à cette notion de suprématie
européenne après la décision du tribunal
correctionnel polonais qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire marie françoise bechtel ce
et cette espèce de corps à la droite est
bien le débat est en fait assez confus
parce qu'il est faussement clair quand
on dit comme il a été très clairement et
très bien rappelé que la constitution
est supérieur aux traités et que donc on
modifie la constitution de pour
naturellement suivre les transferts de
compétences qui vivent dans le traité ça
ne marche et on l'a vu il ya déjà un
certain nombre d'années que lorsque les
compétences en tic clairement désigné
dans la constitution si la cour de
karlsruhe très bien mais
constitutionnellement qui a une nouvelle
alerte le premier dans les années 90 il
a dit je ne respecterai les directives
et où le droit européen dérivés que tant
que haut langue aussi longtemps qu'il
sera confondre fondamentaux que j'ai
inscrit dans la constitution
ensuite au nom du traité de lisbonne ne
traitez vous savez qui a jeté le voile
sur la concision européenne dont les
français ne voulaient pas traité de
lisbonne le les mauvaises langues disent
que les allemands s'ils avaient été
consultés n'aurait peut-être pas voulu
non plus en tout cas le tribunal
constitutionnel de karlsruhe ali mais il
n'existe pas de peuple européen il n'y a
pas un peuple européen par conséquent la
souveraineté reste l'apanage des états
dans ce point est extrêmement mais
pourquoi faire des concessions des
logements les léguer leur souveraine co
écrit aujourd'hui quand je ris parce que
je ris parce qu'aujourd'hui on arrive à
un moment où les traités conçues elles
sont devenus terriblement confluent
d'ailleurs depuis 2009 et le traité de
lisbonne parce que au lieu de définir
des compétences précises auxquelles on
s'engage constitutionnellement prenons
l'exemple la politique agricole commune
il ya longtemps prenons l'exemple du
marché quoi qu'on puisse penser des
règles du marché unique nous nous sommes
engagés mais il arrive un moment où on
veut faire accepter aux états nationaux
tout un déferlement de droit
supranational qui est fixée par les
juges de la cour principalement de la
combustion européenne à certains égards
aussi de la cndh mais il ya un lien
entre les deux leur faire accepter un
certain nombre de principes considérées
comme démocratiques et là ça coince
parce que tous les pays n'ont pas la
même définition de ce que des principes
démocratiques
au regard de la souveraineté nationale
qui appartient au peuple lequel la
délègue à ses représentants voilà et
dans la sphère polonaise comprennent ou
celui-là on est très très très à mon
avis hein on est on est à un niveau qui
est un peu compliqué alors est-ce que
vous avez des exemples concrets tout à
fait dans la sphère polonaise les
polonais désir désignent eux-mêmes les
juges notamment de leur cour suprême
c'est exactement ce que fait la france
le conseil cautionne français est
désigné par les autorités politiques la
france n'a jamais été reprise sur ces
sujets la pologne est repris sur ce
sujet il ya des sujets qui n'ont pas été
délégué par s'il n'y a aucune
désignation clair dans les traités des
compétences correspondantes la démo de
la madone mekla juges constitutionnels
oui le net oui n'est plus indépendant ah
il est sous la coupe du pouvoir
politique et c'est bien pour ça
désormais une procédure d'infraction de
la commission européenne mais contre la
pologne et il ya cet arrière la cour de
justice inflige des amendes à la
pratique du jeu ne sont plus et je
considère qu'une décision devrait sont
constitutionnels est valable je
considère ceci est totalement abusif
parce que nous n'avons pas je crois dans
les traités je prends je suis même sûr
non pas dans des traités délégué le
droit supranational qui consiste à
vérifier indépendance des magistrats
entendus je dois l'armée par exemple
nous y repart en tête tout allait bien
sûr on a du temps bernard guetta écoutez
je crois
le début de notre débat en est la preuve
me semble utile je crois que nous sommes
tombés tous collectivement dans un piège
qui nous a été tendu par les dirigeants
polonais les dirigeants polonais ont dit
soudain mais le débat c'est la primauté
du droit national du droit européen sur
le droit national ou l'inversé la
constitution c'est mais pas du tout le
débat avec lui n'ont pas la pologne mais
avec les dirigeants polonais la
coalition actuelle qui dirige la pologne
le débat at c est ce que cette coalition
respectent ou non le principe
fondamental fondamentale dont toute
démocratie est évidemment que l'union
européenne est un club de démocratie
autrement cela n'a pas de sens autrement
ça n'a pas de sens est ce que les
dirigeants polonais reconnaissent ou
violent
systématiquement l'indépendance de la
justice alors quand on leur pose la
question les dirigeants polonais
répondent l'écouté vous rendez compte
les magistrats de l'époque communiste
était toujours en place il fallait
évidemment que nous les évincerons on
vous dit que l'europe défend ses
principes et notamment le principe
d'indépendance de la justice en
sanctionnant
vous permettez de reprendre à l'aise ils
ne les font pas ces principes elle
défend les principes auxquels l'ensemble
des états membres ont à dire et ont
adhéré en rejoignant l'union européenne
personne le sirha juste terminer la
phrase et personne n'a obligé quiconque
à rejoindre l'union européenne quant à
l'état veut la quitter regardez ce qui
s'est passé avec la grande bretagne est
bas elles quittent ils cliquent l'union
europé alors on n'a pas encore entendu
jean paul garraud je vous donne la
parole faut-il s'inspirer des polonais
monsieur gros oui alors merci je
regardais pas être avec vous sur le
plateau mais on a de temps on va pouvoir
s'exprimer alors ce sujet c'est un sujet
entre juridique mais il est aussi très
politique et nous voyons bien
effectivement que beaucoup de candidats
viennent finalement sur notre terrain
moi j'ai été député ump j'ai toujours eu
la même façon de voir les choses par
rapport à évidemment à toutes ces
questions le débat actuel il est très
intéressant aussi parce que pour une
fois ce débat juridique il devient quand
même dia tic et les journalistes se s'y
intéressent et donc de fait les gens s'y
intéressent aussi alors de quoi
s'agit-il en fait vous avez derrière
toutes les conceptions juridique et je
les unir deux conceptions qui sont des
conceptions politiques qui se traduisent
juridiquement une conception qui est
celle finalement du président la
république et de l'autre un monsieur
macron qu'ils pensent
vraiment très sincèrement qu'il y à une
souveraineté européenne c'est à dire qu
en clair c'est une traduction d'une
sorte de conception un peu fédéralistes
ou l'union européenne serait un supra
est un qui en termes finalement
juridique pourrait donner un certain
nombre de directives finalement aux
états nations dans des domaines y
compris dans des domaines alors il ya
des domaines effectivement qui ont été
transférés mais y compris dans des
domaines qui n'ont pas été transférées
c'est à dire la suprématie du droit
européen la suprématie de l'europe sur
les états nations et tout ceci s'est
construit et ça je tiens à le dire parce
que ce n'est pas mettre en cause les
fondements de l'europe que de contester
finalement cela parce que quand l'europe
a été construite quand l'europe a été
construite elle est traité de rome de
1957 ne mette en aucune façon en avant
la primauté du droit européen bon alors
on a comme ça il ya d'un côté il y en à
côté et que les manuels macro et les
fédéralistes et de l'autre parce qu'il
faut quand même même si vous avez
l'assurance que vous soyez à chaque once
i allez-y mais je reviendrai je vais
revenir là dessus parce que si vous
voulez c'est quand même technique
juridique mais il faut que les français
comprennent que c'est essentiel pour
l'avenir de la france voilà tout
simplement c'est essentiel parce que en
réalité la construction qui s'est faite
de primauté du droit européen s'est
faite par me sujets européens de la cour
de justice des communautés européennes
dans un premier temps c'est le fameux
zhari costa
2964 et ensuite varane ont travaillé de
1970 où peu à peu les juges de la cour
de justice des communautés européennes
et donc les juges la cour de justice de
l'union européenne ensuite se sont
arrogés finalement des droits à peu les
initiateurs
ça suffit' bout
excusez moi de jouer jusqu'à la parole
se se ventile le plus de la façon la
plus équilibrée possible avec j'ai bien
entendu finalement une sorte de
transfert au pouvoir des juges par
glissements successifs qu'est ce que
vous en pensez puis ensuite on ne peut
pas soutenir que l'europe soit soit soit
en club quand vous écrivez sur l'année
le mans dans la constitution que la
république française participe à lyon
européenne constante constituée d'états
qui on consent consenti ils font tous
les mots ont leur poids consenti à
exercer en commun certaines de leurs
compétences c'est entendu désigné par
les traités ça n'est pas un club avec
des règles du jeu la chance joue pas au
hockey c'est pas non plus un club vous
avez dit tout à l'heure je sais pas ce
que vous je ne sais pas mais c'est pas
une révision d'une autorisation pour un
vrai choc dans l'emploi du mot club eh
bien je sais la connotation nous avons
un ensemble de personnes qui se mettent
ensemble de bonne compagnie station vous
change agréablement que je veux c'est la
question qui est posée dans notre
constitution c'est la console le
consentement aux traités et une fois
encore on a consenti à l'appart flair
des traités on n'a pas consenti à la
partie non clair c'est à dire au
déferlement et donc ils ont craint
nationaux willy sont imposés par des
jurys des maisons et donc ses zones
d'ombré donne trop de pouvoirs aux juges
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
idée mais je suis pas d'accord je lai le
jeu les je crois que cette idée je n'ai
pas attendu monsieur garrot pour la pour
l'exprimer jean pierre chevenement 2 de
valider la porte je vais vous prendre
deux exemples tout à fait récent les
juges européens ont décidé que la
directive temps de travail 2003
s'appliquait aux armées françaises
on allait transférer
d'accord le deuxième exemple si la
sphère des données d'écouté téléphonique
sensible en matière de notamment de
lutte contre le terrorisme le juge
européen veut interdire à la france de
conserver ces données y compris dans le
cadre de la lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est directement la souveraineté non
transférées on voit très bien qui est
ici attaqué piste d'une part vous avez
les armes et d'autre part vous avez mais
la justice et la police tout ça n'a
jamais été transféré alors tiens
alexandre vous pouvez venir sur le
plateau on a un peu accéléré le
mouvement il semble tout ça pour
justement vous dire ce qui s'est passé
avec cette directive européenne sur le
temps de travail on vous écoute moi bien
justement est d'ailleurs cette directive
européenne sur le temps de travail c'est
un sujet qui s'invite dans la campagne
présidentielle arnaud montebourg
candidat on a parlé écoutez la
alors est-ce qu'on est près la cour de
justice de l'union européenne a imposé
aux armes et l'union européenne les 35
heures vous croyez qu'on va se battre
avec les 35 heures
alors déjà c'est faux ce que dit arnaud
montebourg ce n'est pas une information
exacte on va regarder précisément ce que
dit cette directive européenne sur le
temps de travail sains qui date de 2003
d'ailleurs c'était la france qui avait
fait pression pour la beauté elle dit
que dans tous les états membres les
travailleurs doivent avoir au moins onze
heures de repos par tranche de 24 heures
travaillées au maximum 48 heures par
semaine et disposer de quatre semaines
de congés par an et en juillet dernier à
la cour de justice de l'union européenne
qui jugeait un conflit entre un soldat
slovène et sa hiérarchie aps a rappelle
que tous les états membres et bien
doivent appliquer cette directive et
qu'elle s'applique aux militaires et
notamment et bien aux militaires qui
relèvent de l'administration de la
réparation de la santé du bien du
maintien de l'ordre ou alors de la
poursuite des infractions notamment des
gendarmes et donc cette directive ne
s'applique pas aux combattants en
opération pense notamment à l'opération
barque anne hommel si oui alors vous
l'aï dit à l'instant l'ironie c'est que
la france en 2003 avait fait voter cette
directive le gouverneur actuel refuse de
l'appliquer oui effectivement la france
avait fait pression pour faire passer
cette directive européenne sur le temps
de travail en 2003 et 18 ans plus tard
ce que dit et bien le gouvernement
actuel c'est que et finalement durant
toute cette période eh bien la france à
appliquer cette directive mais pas assez
armé a les armes et relève de la
souveraineté nationale et donc la
ministre des armées florence parly
estime que ne vois pas pourquoi cela
changerait donc le gouvernement de jean
castex et essaye en ce moment de faire
changer cette directive européenne est
d'ailleurs en juillet dernier un camp
cette décision de justice européenne a
été prise et bien deux jours après cette
décision l'ancien premier ministre
edouard philippe a pris la plume dans
une tribune du monde pour écrire que eh
bien cette décision de la plus haute
juridiction européenne est dans son
principe contraire aux intérêts
nationaux les plus élémentaires elle
touche au coeur de la souveraineté et de
la sécurité de la france elle n'est pas
acceptable le ton est très claire est en
réalité ce bras de fer sur le temps de
travail des armées eh bien ils durent
depuis le début du quinquennat
d'emmanuel maquereau et le président de
la république au début de soutien de son
quinquennat avait même promis aux
gendarmes qu'il allait elle a changé et
qu'elle ne s'appliquerait pas aux
personnels militaires écoutez le sur ce
sujet du temps de travail je dirais
aussi très clairement que ma
détermination
et complète pour qu'eux aussi bien la
gendarmerie t le ministère les armées ne
soient pas concernés par la directive
bien connu les choses sont claires
notifié à qui de droit et seront portés
jusqu'à leur terme
et malgré la détermination des manuel da
cruz 5 ans plus tard cette directive n'a
pas changé elle est toujours appliquée
même avec plus de force mairie régis
l'appliquent à un état souverain mais ce
que je peux en malaisie c'est vraiment
passionnant on dit les juges s'arroge le
pouvoir de et cetera et cetera non les
états membres prennent des directives au
bout de vingt c'est la commission qui
les prend fin
la commission les prend après accord ou
en vérité à l'incitation des états
membres et en l'occurrence la france
poussent à une directive sur le titre on
travaille à l'effroi des états dirigés à
l'époque par des gouvernements libéraux
libéraux au sens économique et dit
comment ça c'est le dirigisme français
c'est absolument épouvantable finalement
la france gagne donc ça c'est beau mais
bon après que font les jumeaux je bats
les juges y vérifie la conformité
de ce que font les différents états avec
les directives européennes qui ont été
adoptées à part la volonté des états
membres alors en l'occurrence je
laissais mois terminée en eux en
l'occurrence ça se retourne contre la
france et je suis absolument contre
l'arrêt de la cour de justice européenne
bien sûr que oui il me semble absolument
aberrant mais de temps en temps la cour
de cassation en france rend un arrêt qui
me semble totalement aberrant et qui
semble à beaucoup de gens totalement
aberrant et beaucoup de gens c'est ouf
d'indignation mais voilà les magistrats
de la cour de cassation ont tranché par
un arrêt est bien la juridiction suprême
dans l'union européenne tranche par un
arrêt conformité ou non conformité au
droit européen qui est créé par les
traités est ce que je parlais un nom pas
tout gagner et vous répondrais appelé au
gouvernement un mot je crois qu'on est
en plein coeur du débat ici c'est très
intéressant parce que j'entendais le
député européen dira oui c'est un débat
juridique mais avant tout politique et
là s'agissant d'un arrêt de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne c'est une
directive est en en plein coeur du débat
une directive dès lors qu'elle a été
votée par les états et applicables de
plein droit il n'y a pas que cette
directive sur l'armée il ya également la
directive sur le contrôle technique des
deux roues vous vous rappelez nous avons
voté une directive est on en train de
dire sa directive finalement elle est
trop vieille pour être applicable dès
lors qu'une directive a été votée à
l'instigation des états validé par le
parlement européen elle et applicables
de plein droit au delà du droit national
premièrement deuxièmement il ya quand
même ce qu'on appelle le bouclier
constitutionnel c'est-à-dire que le
conseil constitutionnel en france a déjà
eu l'occasion de dire que si une
directive présentait certaines
dispositions contraires à l'idée d'une
identité constitutionnel de la france
est bien effectivement cela pourrait
être un élément pour refusé de
l'appliquer sauf qu'aujourd'hui cette
directive a été appliqué et donc je
crois qu'il faut aussi faire preuve de
modération on ne demande pas aux
militaires qui sont sur le terrain en
train d'aller à barkan qui combat être
d'appliquer des réacteurs en étant del
rat on est en train de parler du
personnel administratif dans l'armée est
on en train de dire finalement que cette
directive de son verdict c'est
finalement la constitution le droit
européen et respecté en l'état il n'ya
pas c'est pas parce qu'une décision nous
déplaît qu'il faut tout remettre en
cause ces deux petites sur la visite
nous nous engageons à appliquer une
directive très juste nous sommes engagés
à appliquer une directive met dedans
quels champs d'application de la
directive personne n'a jamais pensé que
la directive interviendrait dans les
domaines qui avait été réservé en des
traités c'est à dire la puissance de
l'état souverain en matière régaliennes
c'est ça le sujet mais les juges ont
élargi le champ d'application la
directive et la deuxième chose c'est que
l'identité conçu est de la france qui a
été inventé en 2004 par le consensus et
a suggéré non elle a été créé inventé je
veux dire elle a été écrite à ce moment
là par le conseil conçu à l'est ne
figure dans aucun texte avant le conseil
de l a dit on doit transposer les
directives sauf s'il s'avérait qu'elle
serait contraire à notre identité quand
sean bean ne l'a jamais jamais jamais
appliqué depuis l'an jamais alors qu'au
contraire de la cour constitutionnelle
allemande qui est d'appliquer le
principe identité consuel allemande à
plusieurs reprises et récemment encore à
propos des euro bonds des de la
politique donc c'est en train mais le
tribunal tantôt sujet
le tribun cautionner construit jamais
validé le plan de relance européen par
exemple il a émis quelques réserves
quelques minutes pour voir plus que
quelques aînés et donc il n'ya il n'a
jamais c'était que d'achat il a toujours
défendu les contribuables allemands
toujours défendu la constitution
allemande mais il n'a jamais empêché
d'un progrès il a refusé de reconnaître
la juridiction de la cour de justice
européenne sur ce sujet
un mot de jean paul garraud vous
répondiez aux arguments de bernard
guetta qui nous dit finalement c'est pas
parce qu'une décision de la cour de
justice européenne nous déplaît qu'il
faut remettre en cause tout le
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes
alors je réponds à votre question mais
d'abord je voudrais simplement dire et
d'une que je ne suis pas comme politique
je suis aussi magistrats et magistrats
de terrain donc je vois la société sur
les questions dont j'ai un peu
l'habitude et ensuite je voudrais dire
aussi que les déclarations du président
de la république sont d'une totale
hypocrisie parce qu'en même temps il dit
il ne va pas appliquer cette directive
est en même temps bien sûr c'est
d'ailleurs une de ses caractéristiques
et bien finalement 7 il fait exactement
l'inversé donc donc nous avons un vrai
problème pour répondre sur la
transposition donc des règles qui est
des directives dans le droit interne par
l'assemblée nationale j'ai été député de
la majorité donc on n'a quasiment aucun
de pouvoir c'est à dire que une
directive qui doit être transposée
dans le droit interne elle est quasiment
automatiquement transposés les
parlements français n'a quasiment aucun
pouvoir par rapport à cela je les fais
l'écho vous l'assuré c'est certain mais
c'est ça s'il ya une majorité qui
s'expriment contre voyons à ce moment là
ce n'est pas transposer ce si ceci étant
dit dans les domaines absolument
essentiel les domaines régaliens dans
lesquelles il n'y a pas de transfert de
compétences il est totalement
inadmissible que la cour de justice de
l'union européenne s'arrogent le droit
de dire un certain nombre de choses il
est totalement inadmissible donc qu'elle
aime pose enfin j'espère que tout le
monde est d'accord avec cela parce que
sinon c'est la souveraineté nationale
qui est évidemment mis en cause et du
conte fait les polonais et roumains les
allemands notamment eh bien ils ont
contesté cela et il y à un mouvement
d'ailleurs intéressant au niveau
européen judiciaire de résistance je
dirais par rapport à tout cela et ça
c'est très très nouveau et je
souhaiterais vraiment que nos
juridictions françaises et notamment nos
juridictions suprêmes en fassent de même
parce que le problème d'un certain
nombre de nos juridictions et de nos
juridictions suprêmes conseil d'état
cour de cassation c'est quelqu'un peut
paraître se sont mises sous la
dépendance dans une sorte de discours un
peu convenus sous la dépendance des
grandes idées un peu généreuse
naturellement qui découle donc de
l'évolution jurisprudentielle de la cour
de justice de l'union européenne alors
ceci c'est dommage parce que
on a bien entendu vos arguments je vais
je vais ouvrir un autre ce jour donnera
la parole à évidemment tout à l'heure
jean paul garraud ouvrir un chapitre de
nouveau un peu plus politique avec vous
laetitia pour pour eux parce que jean
paul garraud évidemment mettait en cause
le voilà les décisions les hésitations
ou les promesses non tenues par par
emmanuel macron comment se se placent le
président de la république on le voit là
avec une forme d'isolement face au
candidat de droite c'est ce que je
disais en début de séquence très
clairement d'ailleurs vous avez
introduit le débat avec la déclaration
d' emmanuel macron qui à mon avis pose
de façon ferme et définitive voilà son
engagement vis-à-vis de l'europe c'était
le 18 octobre dernier à l'ouverture des
états généraux de la justice
tenait pour rester pudique
dans nos débats aujourd'hui de voir que
dès qu'il ya un problème nous en
revenons à cette vieille maladie
française qui consiste à dire c'est
l'europe mais l'europe c'est non c'est
non qui l'avons fait et qui l'avons
choisir c'est nous qui l'avons
construite tous les textes auxquels nous
sommes soumis nous les avons bâti dans
nos discussions puis signer puis ratifié
souverainement je sais que cette affaire
c'est ça va être un argument fort c'est
même à la limite le postulat premier
d'emmanuel macron futur candidat à sa
succession dans la campagne c'est à dire
qu'il sait que sa position qui n'a
jamais finalement bouger 1 depuis qu'il
est arrivé à l'elysée il veut prendre le
leadership de l'europe il défend
l'europe coûte que coûte avec des
arguments il me semble un tout petit peu
plus simple que les veaux de ce soir
parce que le peuple français va devoir
aussi voter sur cette question là parce
que ils sont vent debout tous les
concurrents pour l'instant d'emmanuel
macron sauf peut-être anne hidalgo qui a
encore un petit peu timide sur la
question on n'a pas vraiment sa position
en tout cas ce sera au coeur de la
campagne et il a une petite idée en tête
le président il sait très bien qu'à
partir du 1er janvier la france prend la
présidence de l'union européenne est
donc bien servir évidemment dans la
campagne électorale avec un tout petit
avantage alors on va me dire que c'est
accessoire mais quand même c'est à dire
que le csa va lui permettre de parler de
la présidence française de l'union
européenne sans des comptes et son temps
de parole et donc s'il est habile et on
imagine qui va l'être il pourra
peut-être en tirer avantage tout dépend
dieu du positionnement l'opinion
française sur ce sujet on ne l'a pas
encore vraiment effectivement la
question du temps de parole elle se
posera et ça pour ça pour rien si la
question de l'entrée en campagne
officielle du plan la bulle mais ça
c'est un autre débat qu'on aurait sous
pression la république quand il a parlé
c'était 2 lors de sa première campagne
présidentielle lorsqu'il a parlé d'une
souveraineté européenne ne faisait pas
du tout allusion au débat qui nous agite
aujourd'hui c'était pas du tout ça il
disait
la souveraineté de la france est
aujourd'hui menacée parce que nous
n'avons pas de suffisamment de moyens
notamment militaires mais aussi
industriel économique diplomatique et
c'est là pour peser sur la scène
internationale et donc je défends une
souveraineté de l'union européenne qui
elle peut peser sur la scène
internationale et tendre à devenir
vous dis c'est un fantasme tendres donc
à devenir un acteur la scène
internationale et là vous dit une chose
très intéressante est absolument
fondamental c'est un fantasme parce que
nous n'avons pas de défense est bien
lourd aujourd'hui dans l'union
européenne depuis maintenant 6 mois 1 an
en vérité depuis cinq ans l'idée d'une
défense européenne commune n'est plus du
tout un tabou est aujourd'hui totalement
admise par tous les états membres par
les 27 états membres à cette défense
commune demain matin non il faut 15 ans
pau
sebha sud on veut parler d'abord
je
vous dise il faut parler simplement
effectivement il faut qu'ils comprennent
ce que l'europe a écouté les
agriculteurs qui depuis les années 60
reçoit des subsides de l'union
européenne qui sont très contents de
pouvoir monter des grandes exploitations
agricoles et j'en ai visité eh bien ils
sont très contents qui est l'europe
voilà est aujourd'hui est ce qu on est
pour ou est-ce qu'on est contre l'europe
est-ce qu'on veut détruire est-ce qu'on
veut d'être la construction européenne
est ce qu'on veut la poursuivre et c'est
ça les enjeux aujourd'hui au delà de
deux enjeux juridiques nous ce sera se
serait attendu à ce qui va la triste si
vous voulez c'est de voir que très peu
de responsables politiques et bien
défendre vraiment véritablement l'europe
qui a été porté depuis des années par
des faits rebours d'atr est ce qu'elle
est parfaite lors elle n'est pas
parfaite il faut continuer à l'améliorer
il ya une conférence sur l'europe
aujourd'hui il ya très peu de personnes
qui parlent positivement de l'europe et
puis c'est passionnant politique
rené aujourd'hui à les instrumentaliser
à débat juridique à des fins purement
politiques et politiciennes et sa
ferrari françoise mais pas parfaite et
j'ai surtout gravement déficient mais
surtout ce que vous dites là moi je
l'entends depuis 20 ans je donc c'est un
discours très ressasser attention
l'europe nous a protégés vous le savez
bien dire nous voulons demain une europe
qui protège davantage et au fur et à
mesure le discours se développer les
fons et voyez quand même la concurrence
des travailleurs à bas coûts les
directives mâché unis qui sont une folie
que l'europe est le seul continent à
faire à ce degré là d'ailleurs dans le
monde et pendant ce temps les français
voient deux immenses état souverain est
un souverain nations souveraines qui
sont les états unis et la chine se
développer
attendez
c'est là que je voulais enchaîner avec
ce que vous dites je reconnais au
président à craon le fait qu'il a
compris l'idée qu'il fallait ce qu'il
appelle souveraineté européenne ça veut
dire en réalité n dépendance européenne
texas que le général de gaulle appelait
l'europe européenne mais est d'ailleurs
il est significatif qu'aujourd'hui tout
le monde hurle contre la pologne moi je
n'ai pas de sympathie pour le régime
polonais je le dis tout de suite mais je
pense qu'il ya quand même un vrai sujet
de savoir si la magistrature et tous non
dans les traités je pense qu'elle n'est
pas parce que c'est régaliens mais
personne n'a hurler lorsque la pologne a
acheté des armes américaines ou
d'acheter des armes chance par exemple
on ne vous entend davantage donc et tout
ça est quand même très significatif la
question or la question d'indépendance
européenne est absolument pas contraire
à la souveraineté des nations au sein
d'une autre nation qu'ils construiraient
ensemble un grand modèle avec des
projets technologiques spatiaux
numérique de recherche y compris médical
de brevets et pour ça on n'a pas besoin
de 3000 directives par ange dû au hasard
on n'a pas besoin un candidat à la
présidentielle l'a dit assez bien il
anime et laissez donc les gens
tranquilles depuis peu chez eux je
reprendrai mon besoin de très grands
projets européens pour nous mais pour
cela je finis il faut que ce soit des
nations souveraines conscients de leur
souveraineté d'une certainement fier
mettre leurs moyens en commun
la phrase du présent et public une
vieille maladie française ses attaques
contre l'europe et d'ailleurs je peux y
inclure mais je suis pas sûr je peux y
inclure d'ailleurs les médias parce que
parler de leur hausse a toujours été une
espèce de repoussoir à audience et donc
on en parlait le moins possible à
marietta vous avez votre expérience pour
vous savez un jour un éditeur mais
c'était il ya sept ou huit heures me
demande un livre sur l'union européenne
je m'abonne le manuscrit inédit bull le
titre bon surtout pas le moule on s'est
tapé mon cher éditeurs écouter soyons
conséquents
mais enfin voilà mais vous savez bien
sûr c est ce que c'est une vieille
maladie française prouesse que c'est
dépassé saleh dans l'esprit des français
ce déni d'europe je pense que la
boulimie médiatique les politiques je
pense que la classe politique de droite
comme de gauche ont globalement
des correspondants locaux de l'actuelle
médias puisque sont largement
responsables du fait qu'ils marchandent
est ce que c'est un creuset s'appelle
l'imaginaire français c'est à dire
l'idée qu'on peut se projeter dans un
projet défense besoin d'aller au delà
éventuellement dur frontières d'ailleurs
mais d'avoir un grand projet vers
lesquels on puisse les mobiliser ce
grand projet on n'a jamais parce que le
marché unique est quelque chose qui
divise les travailleurs le capital
lui-même aussi d'ailleurs et encore une
fois nous met dans une situation où nous
sommes devenus le ventre mou du monde au
lieu d'être quelque chose qui puisse
avancer aller de l'avant le ciel le voir
emmanuel macron lorsqu'il dit que taper
sur l'europe c'est une bonne chose à des
fins de politique intérieure ça fait des
années qu'ils aujourd'hui défend
l'europe j'ai ma moto du responsable
politique et je ne citerai pas nous
parler des aides des ayatollahs de
bruxelles mais ça veut dire quoi c'est
grave ah ça veut dire que plus on tape
sur le dos de l'europe mieux c'est son
célèbre la beauté assez grave vous ferez
une fois ils sont tout trouvés avec un
élément qu'on a prévu pour cette
émission c'est une réaction de marine le
pen récente 1 lors de sa visite en
hongrie à et auprès du premier ministre
viktor orban
si je suis élue présidente de la
république française le 24 avril
prochain de vous apporter le soutien de
la france et de son peuple pour
réorienter une union européenne dont la
brutalité ou théologiques attentes à
l'idée même de souveraineté l'union
européenne n'est plus nous savons une
organisation internationale intel un
national entre les nations elle a dérivé
en organisation fédérale puis en
véritable pouvoir centralisé bruch ses
lois enivré de sa propre existence de sa
puissance de son omnipotence
bernard guetta votre section et ensuite
le camarade de classe de monsieur organe
qui était devenu de monsieur van le
premier y seront à l'ami de madame le
pen ce camarade de classe était devenu
un chauffagiste il est aujourd'hui
l'homme le plus riche de hongrie l'homme
le plus riche de hongrie et quand vous
demandez à n'importe quel endroit mais
c'est lui l'homme de plus riches de
hongrie où les gens et clins d'oeil et
19 ses organes ses orba ben c'est dès
qu'il ya un problème
angry de corruption mais immense immense
digne du tiers-monde
deuxièmement monsieur organe a fait
acheter par ses amis
commerciaux ou industriels financiers
etc la majeure partie écrasante de la
presse hongroise il n'y a plus ou
pratiquement plus de presse hongroise
indépendante
la hongrie vire vers une dictature et
madame le pen va embrasser comme
monsieur zemmour l'avait fait une
semaine auparavant va embrasser monsieur
organes contre l'union européenne qui
défend qui défend quoi la démocratie
je l'avais dire ah bon vous ne savez
plus ce que c'est que la démocratie mois
ci qui défend la démocratie qu'ils
défendent la lutte contre la corruption
qui défend la lutte contre la corruption
qui défend évidemment la liberté de la
presse et l'indépendance de la justice
moi je ne comprends pas et bernard
guetta vous savez de quoi vous parler
puisque je rappelle vous avez publié
vous publiez l'enquète hongrois c'est
chez flammarion jean paul garraud
répondez à bernard guetta c'est le
modèle c'est le modèle effectivement de
de la droite nationaliste de la droite
souverainiste appelons la comme vous
voulez pour ne pas dire l'extrême droite
je sais que vous n'aimez pas qu'on
emploie ce mot est ce qu'il faut aller
se montrer aux côtés de viktor orban
écoutez on n'est pas là franchement pour
juger nos voisins les peuples les états
la souveraineté c'est aussi le respect
des autres états qui ont qui auront tout
à fait démocratiquement élu ceux qui les
gouvernent alors j'entends toujours d'un
certain milieu comme ce que je viens
d'entendre un enjeu critique personne
mais quand même toujours le même
discours convenu si vous voulez et ça
c'est honnêtement ça ne marche plus
voilà parce que ça ne marche plus chez
les gens ils ne lisent supporte plus ce
genre de discours je le dis très
franchement maintenant les hongrois les
tchèques les allemands les roumains les
polonais sont des nations totalement
nous râble et il n'est pas question de
se porter un jugement de valeur sur ceux
qui les gouvernent puisqu'ils ont été
élus démocratiquement mais qu'est ce que
c'est ce mal français de vouloir faire
la leçon au monde entier regardez vous
regardons nous vous voyez bien où nous
en sommes ici en france vous croyez que
nous sommes véritablement un exemple
pour le monde entier à certains sont des
100 me sur l'échiquier
sujet on peut encore s concernent des
sujets parce que je considère que la
france d'un point de vue économique et
l'autre est descendu bien bas et que
maintenant nous sommes dans une
situation de très délicat on parlait
d'un des réseaux ferroviaires les
corrections parler de corruption s'est
pas exactement le même le maire
allez-y mari personnellement je pense
que l'élargissement à l'est ça a été
fait autour du mans est beaucoup trop
vite parce que c'est vrai que les pays
n'avançait pas du même pas y compris
économiquement il n'est pas étonnant qui
n'est pas un rêve non plus les mêmes
standards démocratiques il n'y a pas de
surprise derrière ça mais en réalité on
ne fait jamais le procès d'un pays comme
les pays bas qui sont un véritable
paradis fiscal alors qu'aujourd'hui un
paradis fiscal s'agit d'un jour ont
aujourd'hui qui exigent en europe qui
tape du poing sur la table pour que les
pays bas qui font la leçon toute la
journée sur l'austérité budgétaire aux
autres pays et sur le plan de relance et
sur son conditionnement qui est-ce qui
tape sur la table pour exiger qu'ils se
mettent aux normes on peut prendre
également d'autres exemples alors cette
fois
les questions fiscales accordées oui
bien sûr mais qui elle est important
qu'ils aient les mêmes et qui a poussé
as assisté précisément l'union
européenne je pense enfin
arrivé bon en fait sans doute être
je voudrais
ensuite et de la même manière d'ailleurs
alors cette fois je parle pas des états
mais je parle d'un organe extrêmement
important qui je crois n'est pas hors
sujet qui est la commission européenne
la commission européenne et composé de
commissaires qui sont souvent liées à
des lobbys sans aucun contrôle en france
on demande un ministre de faire une
déclaration devant une autorité
indépendante a acheté vp et on le
sanctionne s'il parle de là où nous
avons vu monsieur barroso qui est parti
chez goldman sachs ce qui en dit très
long sur les intérêts qu'ils avaient
poussé quand il était à la commission
nous avons eu la commissaire neelie
kroes je crois qui était commissaire à
la concurrence pas cette fois ci qui
était qui étaient dans des conseils
d'administration de grands groupes et
qu'est ce que c'est que cette europe les
gens voient ça
c'est bien regardez aujourd'hui de
contrôler et
puis votre mot de la fin parce qu'on est
quasiment la famille le parlement exerce
ou pâti
du parlement européen je suis effaré du
nom de contrevérités que j'ai pu
entendre ce soir sur ce plateau ou
ailleurs sur l'europe c'est important
vous fier d'aider débat là dessus ce que
je veux dire c'est que lorsqu'on dit que
là il ne s'agit pas de donner des leçons
aux autres états mais lorsque la cour le
tribunal constitutionnel polonais ne
veut plus de la supériorité du droit
européen il ne veut plus de l'article 2
qui parle de la tolérance de la
démocratie de l'indépendance des juges
et du respect des minorités c'est ça
aujourd'hui la violation des traités
européens c'est ce que veut le glas paul
on sait ce que veut la hongrie et c'est
ce que nous ne voulons pas nous
aujourd'hui comme vous dites que c'est
une question de valeurs
respect des valeurs démocratiques
c'est précisément ce qu'a remis en cause
n'est pas allé on attend on a eu la
parole vous avez eu les uns et les
autres la parole et c'était passionnant
merci beaucoup merci à tous ici sur ce
plateau merci également en
visioconférence à jean paul garraud
bernard guetta je vais réciter le titre
de votre livre l'enquète hongrois c'est
chez flammarion patrick martin geniez
l'europe at elle un avenir on a cru
comprendre avec vos réponses que c'était
oui et c'est chez study rama merci
laetitia à très bientôt sur ce plateau
jeux